alors lui est ce que vous me connaissez
[Rires]
un terrain gremlins je suis d'accord
mais bon c'est quand vos yeux ça toutes
les fautes en vertu de cette méchante
est-ce que vous accepterez que ce soit
des visiteurs non pour faire de l'aide
aux devoirs oui mais pendant le baby
sitter lui est ce que vous connaissez je
connais absolument pas je sais que c'est
un homme politique ou quelque chose
comme ça ce qui vous inspire confiance
non parce qu'on dirait hors la loi quand
il était enfant il tait intello ouais il
travaille à un boulot très difficile
alexandre bonnet à la confiance
j'aime bien que ce soit maintenant sous
contrat mais vraiment bien il dit pas
qu'il apporta à quesques et de police et
il a il alla il a tapé des personnes
avec ses pieds tous à quelque chose oui
un détail mais si c'est fou parce que tu
reconnais personnes depuis le début est
lui tout de suite ça s est bien entendu
parler à la radio
[Musique]
arthur je discute avec toi je comprend
ce qui se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]